you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with Daily Mirror
Economist Susie Boniface and the deputy
editor of conservative home Henry Hill
they'll be with us from now right up
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
brexit deal within days that's the front
of the times which has Rishi sunak on
the verge of solving the Northern
Ireland protocol problem after talks
with the EU president
and that story also makes the lead in
tomorrow's Telegraph
the financial times goes with a warning
from the West to any country aiding the
Russian war effort against Ukraine that
they would face severe costs
the mail leads with the plea from the
mother of a woman whose daughter was
killed by her estranged husband not to
release him on parole after serving a
half of a 26-year jail term
the express reports that the queen
consorts remarks on Thursday have forced
a u-turn on the decision to change parts
of some books by Roald Dahl in case they
caused offense to new readers
the star returns to the fruit and veg
shortage in our shops attacking
government minister to raise coffee for
her suggestion that people should eat
turnips instead
while the mirror says her suggestion has
backfired and put the government in a
stew
simply a vegetable one and a reminder
that by scanning the QR code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Daily
Mirror Economist Susie Boniface and the
deputy editor of conservative home Henry
Hill welcome to you both let's start
with the telegrapher the front page of
the telegraph
and uh Rishi sunette hopes to secure a
new brexit deal for Northern Ireland
over the weekend he's hoping to secure
this deal
um there have been various interventions
and uh his his route to securing this
deal has not been
easy shall we say Susie
but yeah I can swear I saw exactly the
same headlines last weekend when Rishi
Cena was on the brink of a breakthrough
brexit deal uh we've got the same now it
seems that um we are getting to you know
further to the point where there may be
some kind of fudge but don't let the
viewers be disabused here rishi's soon
act hasn't fixed the central problem of
brexit which was that we have one land
border with the EU and it's a land
border we're not allowed to control uh
if you're going to leave the EU you have
to have an edge you have to have a
border in order that you can
um you know demarc the difference
different areas where you have different
tax regimes different regulatory regimes
different customs and so on and so forth
and you can't do that with the northern
Irish Border we're not able to do that
under the Good Friday agreement and what
we've got here is we're basically
um a series of
talks have got to the point where the LA
not the last prime minister sorry the
last prime minister and then another one
Boris Johnson was told that his law to
try and fix the brexit deal was going to
be illegal and was going to be
challenged the international courts if
he pushed it through and so wish you
sooner because had no choice but to try
and renegotiate a better deal he does
appear to have got something better
let's not criticize the man for that and
he's done it without Willy waving which
Boris Johnson did an awful lot of
without threatening to invade anybody or
um you know rustling any any Flags or
anything like that but unfortunately it
still involves treating Northern Ireland
differently to the rest of the United
Kingdom it doesn't matter how you
package it we will be treating Northern
Ireland and sending Goods to and from
Northern Ireland in a way that we do not
for Scotland and Wales and therefore
we're treating the people of Northern
Ireland differently even though they are
full citizens of the United Kingdom that
breaches what was on the brexit
referendum ballot paper it breaches our
own internal laws creating the union
with Northern Ireland in the first place
but it's probably the best they're going
to be able to find but it is a fudge
however it's all about now this is where
we're going down to the last hurdle here
is actually how it's packaged and how
it's sold to people and it will be sold
to you as a solution it's not a solution
it's a fudge and Henry we still don't
know whether the new agreement will be
accepted by the Democratic unionist
party and they've demanded that European
courts have no say whatsoever in
Northern Ireland so that hasn't been
resolved as far as We Know
no it hasn't uh fundamentally Richie
sumac is is carrying a cross that was
built for him by previous Prime
Ministers especially actually Theresa
May because in fact the text of the
Belfast agreement does not mandate that
the UK cannot control the land border it
was basically a political decision that
was made by the May government that
there should be absolutely no
infrastructure on the land border that
was locked in with the EU during her
stage of the negotiations and now
obviously they were they're unwilling to
grow back from that and that does
fundamentally change Northern Ireland's
position in the United Kingdom and the
unionist argument and it's not just the
dep all of the unionist parties opposed
to the protocol is that this is a breach
of the terms in which they signed the
Belfast agreement in the first place
there's real disjuncture in the
government's strategy on this because
constitutionally Rishi sunak can agree a
deal with the European union he can have
it signed off in Parliament labor have
said they will back it that's fine but
the timeline of these negotiations from
the beginning has basically been about
getting storm on the Northern Ireland
devolved assembly back up and running in
time for April which is the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast agreement
when Joe Biden visit and everyone wants
to kind of celebrate that achievement
and that's not going to work if the dep
don't accept it so there's a real gap
between Richie sumac's timetable which
is geared around that storm or deadline
and his determination to strike a deal
with the European Union force it through
Parliament when he hasn't squared the
dup the problem with this and this goes
all the way back really to David Cameron
is that there is just this habit of
negotiating deals privately with
Brussels and then presenting them to
Northern Ireland when in fact the people
of Northern Ireland on both sides need
to be in the room you can't be making
these deals in private and then selling
them to unionism at the last minute and
hoping they back down and if they don't
back down well you've built up enough
head of steam that you have to push on
anyway Rishi sunak should have known
when he was negotiating or when his team
was negotiating whether this would be
acceptable to the dup he should not be
finding it out at this stage in the
process but we read that the
conservative MPS have been told that
they must turn up at the House of
Commons on Monday uh this being a
further sign that expects the deal to be
ready so we shall keep our eyes peeled
on on that one let's move on to the
times and obviously it's the first
anniversary of the war in Ukraine today
president zielinski saying that um they
need more weapons
to to bring this to a conclusion again
making it another appeal for weapons
Susie
yeah and I can understand the reluctance
that some NATO countries have had to try
and get too stuck into some kind of a
quagmire actually to be going to be seen
obviously to be going toe-to-toe with
Russia but the simple fact is this was a
war that Russia cannot win it was
expecting a three-day War it's been
there for a year it is bogged down it is
but it is throwing human beings at the
front line without apparently noticing
or caring how many of them survived the
process it is shelling from a distance
and it has control of the air it can
therefore Pummel Ukraine it can't win
but Russia can Pummel Ukraine for a long
time to come and eventually Ukraine
which does not have its own defense
industry in the way that many other
nations do is going to run out of ways
of Defending itself and what could get
overrun to some extent now Ukraine
itself also cannot win it's too small
it's just not got enough in terms of the
troops and the equipment to do do it but
if it's armed properly if it's given air
defense systems if it's given tanks if
it is given the ability to control some
of its own airspace then far more than
it can now with a handful of migs then
it has a real chance of being able to
push Russia back to the borders and to
re-establish those borders and keep them
safe and that's in everybody's interest
because if Russia overruns Ukraine in
any way or manages to wear it down then
that's next door next step is going to
be Germany the next step is going to be
pushing further into Europe and other
NATO countries it's Finland it's Sweden
it's the other nations which are right
on the edge of Eastern Europe then which
don't need that and it would be very
very dark for all of us so it is in our
best interests to find a way
through the the difficulty we've got
with um not wanting to have all-out
conflict with Russia but needing to arm
Ukraine and zelenski's right if he gets
the weapons he can win it because
there's nothing that fights as strong
and as hard as people who are fighting
for their Homeland that's what
ukrainians have done it's what they are
doing is what they'll continue to do
it's what the Russians absolutely aren't
doing that's why they're relying on
Mercenaries and former prisoners who the
mirror has been interviewing this week
who've been sold a pack of lies about
why they're there and how they're going
to be armed we've also got elsewhere in
the papers today that um the head of the
wavner group these mercenaries is
furious at the defense minister in
Russia because his men aren't even
getting Munitions they're having to take
them down to the front line throw them
at the Ukrainian guns and they haven't
even got enough arms themselves to have
any chance of a fight so it's an
absolute bloodbath and the only way
really is it's the humanitarian option
to bring this conflict to an end as
quickly as possible and that involves
giving Ukraine the tools and the muscle
muscle that it needs to stand up to this
bully okay Henry take us to another
story in in the times this is about a
crime Crackdown which we read is set to
push prison numbers past a hundred
thousand
Yeah so basically the government there's
a lot of public dissatisfaction about
the fact that people who are convicted
of crimes end up being released for
often only serving half their their on
paper sentence because of the current
rules about being eligible for parole
after that time and so the government
said right uh for many crimes I'm not
sure if it's all crimes it's now going
to be two-thirds minimum tariffs before
you are released uh they're also
increase in increasing police numbers
which could mean more convictions and
more people going into the prison system
this is a problem because there's only
so much space in the prison system and
the Civil Service and the prison system
are very worried that there's going to
be this inflow of new prisoners at the
same time as they're having to hold on
to current prisoners for for longer than
they currently have and that's going to
strain capacity because fundamentally if
you want to pursue this kind of you know
High uh imprisonment system which is a
perfectly legitimate system and not to
the public would like it you do need to
have invested in building lots of
prisons in fact the only thing you know
the government's opened a few it also
randomly shut one because Kenneth Clark
didn't want like the fact that it was in
a castle hmp Lancaster Castle was shot a
few years ago
um but so the government has not built
enough prisons the prison estate is too
small and it's now creating potentially
this huge pressure which is going to
cause problems of Standards it's going
to create problems for prisoners and
ultimately will probably mean a reverse
of the policy if more prison space is
not provided relatively quickly Susie
we've just got to less than a minute to
talk turnips
um the toriesonists to overturn it how
so
yes well because I haven't told everyone
that um there's a problem with tomatoes
and cucumbers it's definitely not to do
with brexits Therese coffee suggested
people eat turnips instead and the
problem with that is we don't have
enough turnips largely because of brexit
and the main turnip grower in the UK has
actually stopped growing them because
they can't get the um labor anymore
thanks to the EU labor shortages uh
since brexit and also actually pick the
damn things and what people don't seem
to realize and Therese coffee especially
doesn't realize is we grow about produce
about five billion turnips a year in
this country if every human in this
country was to have one turnip a day we
would need about 25 billion we don't
have enough turnips to feed us most of
our turnips are used to feed livestock
and so that reduces the amount we have
as well we import all our turnips
because we don't have enough here and
guess where we get our turnips from
Europe it's a really Sticky Wicket isn't
it
uh yes you might might call it that
um Harry
your view on the the turnip situation
some supermarkets have taken them off
the shelf
yeah I mean ultimately if you're a
government Minister there should be is
there a school there should be a school
for this if there's a government
Minister and there's a shortage of
something you don't recommend that
people eat something else because you
just invite this kind of this kind of
press coverage you know let them eat
turnips is a headline that writes itself
and the fact that a government Minister
walked into this trap is absolutely
extraordinary you know you can the
shortest if you've got a shortage it's a
bad political story or one of many for
this government at the moment but you
don't needlessly poor media kerosene on
it by making those remarks and it really
speaks I think to the the political
Judgment of Therese coffee but she did
it